on the program they're the chief
executive of the Jockey Club Nevin
Truesdale Nevin a very good morning to
you and first and foremost how did you
feel uh that the meeting went at the
weekend
well I think from one perspective
um very well with fantastic racing
spectacle brilliant crowd Liverpool has
ever really really impressed it and um
whether we did have a very good three
days so you know a Britain's second
biggest spectator sport but we can't
ignore
um what happened in terms of uh the
fatalities that we saw and every
fatality in wrestling is one too many
um and that's obviously a concern to all
of us across the whole sport because we
investing you know race course officials
trainers jockeys owners table staff
especially the stable staff really
really care about the exact point
athletes these fantastic equine Heroes
and to see three fatalities and
condolences to all connections
um across the across the the event
obviously is something we will be
analyzing and reviewing the the fact is
that 99.8 of horses across all of racing
come back from the races safely that's
condone
um that's after target has come down by
a third in the last 10 years the sport
is safer the Grand National is probably
safer than it has ever been but that
does not mean that we will stop
um in terms of our our Relentless drive
to improve welfare standards and that's
obviously the one um negative that's
come out of what was otherwise
um a very very good weekend and a
fantastic winner of the Grand National
and with other great Syndicate who
haven't dumped horses before yeah but
with respect Nevin I mean every time
that this happens doesn't BHA doesn't
the Jockey Club say exactly the same
thing that we understand the affection
that you have for these animals but this
does continue to happen I mean the rspca
are calling for the Urgent review to
result in as never and never again
exiting a festival of racing with three
dead horses and that's from the rspca
you will never eliminate risk completely
um and the factors we have taken very
significant steps over the last few
years to deliver the Improvement um to
welfare and and that I've mentioned in
my previous answer and we will continue
to do that and we will continue to work
with Charities like the rspca and World
horse welfare who help us make
constructive suggestions
um about how we can continue to evolve
the sport and move for the times and
change now that's exactly what we've
done that's exactly what we have been
doing on ourselves the Jockey Club all
the other risk courses across the the
the country plus the BHA obviously
helping us to as a independent regulator
helping to lead that process so it's an
ongoing Relentless process new
um and we have seen
um overall fatality rates decrease
significantly as a result of all that
um
any Walk of Life
just on that point but when when you
saying you've said it several times now
that you can never eliminate risk in
events such as this I mean isn't that
just a very obvious acceptance of the
fact that horses will die again at
meetings like the national and other
meetings around the country particularly
on the jumps you know we're never
accepting of that but the fact is that
there's actually more of a chance for
starring at home with an accident in the
bed or any animal that there is on a
race course with the Tinder Russell
herself the winning Trader not a double
grand national winning Trader Severus
helped an interview yesterday but she
feeds her horses or perceived her on a
race course than they are pretty much
anywhere else these horses are born and
bred to raise new without bracing
without this sort of racing there is no
Thoroughbred because racing drives
breeding salty drives and the
sustainable sustainability of the breed
itself these horses are Born to Race and
without them without racing there isn't
fair bit without Thoroughbred there is
no racing they are inextricably linked
the trainer of Hill 16 very specifically
blames those those protesters that we're
looking at at the moment for
contributing to his horse's death I mean
would you agree with that
first of all there's absolutely some of
the pictures you've shown there are
actually peaceful protesters
um expressing their opinion outside the
gate I won't custom of them
um on Saturday night on the way out and
we have absolutely no problem with that
that is perfectly legitimate people
expressing their opinions
unfortunately some have decided to take
the law into their own hands indeed
break the law because that is let's be
clear that is what happened
um at the injury on salary at about ten
to five between that and this and the
start of the race
um and there is no doubt that there
there is a link between the delay to the
race
um the impact on the horses and
um the the the the the the views of
Sandy who I spoke to on Saturday evening
and you know like any trainer any
connection when you lose a horse he was
um I mean guttered and sad and I I think
his comments certainly is something that
we need to look at because
um there's definitely
um there's there's definitely no
coincidence between the fact that for
example the first two fences on Saturday
we saw eight followers or or on seats of
jockeyed
um I was against 17 in the nine years
before that those two fences indeed I
don't think that's a coincidence but but
never just just to kind of reiterate the
point that I've made already we
understand from the British Horse Racing
authority that there will be a full
review there will be a they will analyze
the racing the race is involved in
painstaking detail but when you the
chief executive Jockey Club say look we
cannot eliminate the risk I mean what is
the purpose of this review what more can
be done is there anything more that can
be done that you haven't done already
well there's plenty that's been done
already
um if you look at the changes to the
ground conditions you're about we're not
running this great we're some good I'm
good um soft ground good soft ground but
slows the horses done makes it much
safer you know the course record in 1990
Mr Frisk will never be beaten because
upgrades was wrong on firm ground change
the nature of the fences completely you
run off areas around defenses
um changes to the to the entry
conditions qualification of the horses
inspections of the horses before the
races we assume outside has already been
done to make this race zoom up safer but
look we analyzed the race every year
um and we look at changes every year and
we I think barely a year has gone by
even during the period where we had no
fatalities in the Grand National between
2013 and 2018 not a single fatality
during that period we were still
reviewing the changes we could make we
were still looking at the improvements
we could make so look it'd be unfair of
me to sit here now two days after the
race and speculate on the sort of
changes we might make but there's always
more we can do no rhyme to start around
the Improvement of this handling of
loose horses roley awards from World
horse welfare refer to some of those
um issues in his statement on another
degree
um those are all those
um all of those issues all of those
factors should should be on the table